one of the issues we have with the
situation is right now we have
thanksgiving on thursday and actual
elections going on on tuesday and
several of our counties around the state
so we're trying to take them on to
account we've given them the specific
procedures of how to do logic and
accuracy testing which follows the
100 test deck i've been talking about
and
the ways that they need to make sure
they keep their provisionals
all together their absentee in person or
early voting altogether
the absentee by mail all together and
the election day altogether
and then we can still report by precinct
and by ballot type
uh there are several questions again
around you know
specific procedures how do we do this
what's a bad just renaming things when
we
run it through and we had reps from the
vendor dominion there
and our staff and kind of walked through
a lot of that
and we sent out some spreadsheets and
lost a lot more forms because i do the
same custody tracking
with each one of these things um we
anticipate some will be working over the
weekend
and as far as the costs go officially
right now it is a county cost
but as i said before we're working with
them to do a cost sharing thing based
out of our java dollars so i
re-emphasize to them that the biggest
cost obviously is personnel
and they need to keep a separate
accounting of that when they're going to
try to
try to look for a way that we can
potentially do a cost sharing on that
using our federal
help america vote act dollars so that's
the biggest highlights they're going to
begin tomorrow morning
by nine they can't have any earlier than
that but beginning can also be if
they're organized and getting the people
lined up
because we want to make sure we have a
lot of notice go out so that the
monitors can be there and adjudication
teams can be lined up especially if they
can view the absentee boats first
because those are the ones that are most
likely that need to be needing
adjudication
and we've passed and reach up their
local parties um
unlike the audit and we made we made
sure that this time
they're going to let us know so we have
a centralized location of where we're
going to be able to show
these things are happening and instead
of giving a we'll begin at 9 00 a.m
on wednesday and end at midnight on the
following wednesday or tuesday and
start beginning at 9am on tuesday and
end at midnight the following wednesday
we're now saying they need to be more
discreet about when the actual work will
be going on because especially in
smaller counties it's harder to get
monitors there to make sure they can
keep the process
um viewable and public because the whole
key to this is transparency
so with that i'm going to go ahead and
uh start taking any questions you might
have
that's the biggest change from earlier
is that we've given them these specific
deadlines
and when they have what they have to do
so walter who's up well the first one
out of the shoot is uh dave wickard
again
so he's quick on the draw i noticed that
hey mr sterling um uh i'm assuming that
you will not be releasing results again
until the
count is complete is that right well
actually in this case it's
it's a different situation in the audit
you're trying not to hit a specific mark
so in this case what's going to happen
is when they are done with their results
within the county
you have to set up a different election
program inside the ems
and on the icc scanner so they're going
to take those results load them into the
ems
and put them into a new election night
reporting page that we're building out
right now
so you could potentially see it's not
going to be like an election night when
you're getting partial results as you go
through the night it's going to
basically be here's everything from one
county here's everything from another
county that's the way it looks like it's
going to be right now
there's nothing saying they can't give
you partial results as they go but i
think it would be a lot
safer and easier just to give the entire
account from each county as it goes but
as you can imagine these smaller
counties will come in first smaller
counties in the state tended to go for
president trump but again we're not
we're going to be looking for
making sure it's lining up with what
those kind of results originally were
so it's a different set of rules around
an audit versus a recount so i think as
as they come into us we will probably
upload it periodically
maybe twice a day or something we
haven't really made that decision but
it will not be everything all at once at
one time it'll be as the counties get
them in
we look at it you know sanity check it
and then we will release it on our
election
page and you wouldn't expect though the
the outcome
election to change a third time around
we had the initial count we had an audit
to confirm that initial account
we had a a difference in balance of
0.1053 percent
and a different margin of 0.0099
so and that's what human error are
involved so my my assumption is
when we use the machines again we should
be hitting right about the same number
about
valid difference about 12 000 i
i'm not going to select my brain 670 or
760 camera
is right now but there is adjudication
involved so there is going to be a human
element on some of these ballots
potentially that could potentially
change the outcome as well
um
change the margin by three or four or
five or something like that i mean we
don't know exactly what it'll be
but when you're dealing with human
beings doing this again handling this
paper for another time
there's always that possibility and i
say shannon i think by changing the
winner and talk about changing potential
margins
within a precinct or within a county
sure and uh
what will be the final what's what will
be the final official results want to
make sure i understand which count gets
counted as i understand it
this count under the code of georgia
will be the certified version of the
count
and if y'all could get the what is the
official margin right now
if you could get that i'd appreciate it
i i had it earlier and then i questioned
myself
and let me take a look there with me a
second
all right 74
507. minus 61
837. 12 670.
12 670. thank you well 670. all right
thanks dave
all right next we have uh zach montelero
yeah hey gabe um sorry pretty dumb
question
when you say midnight on november or
december 2nd that is
wednesday going into thursday correct
that is wednesday going into the third
place
uh this is essentially the same deadline
we had for the hand on it
got it just want to double check that
that's it thank you thanks
all right stephen fowler hey gabe got a
couple questions for you
um first with um
the results georgia reports its results
down to the precinct level and so
will we be able to see with this recount
the variations at the precinct level
with the reporting
yes because there's basically indicators
on each one of the ballots as to what
what precinct is assigned to
so we should be able to track that along
and that's why we're also doing it in
those four separate buckets to make sure
that everything lines up on ballot style
within the precinct itself as well right
and then um
you know in regards to transparency and
monitoring um
a lot of there's been a lot of confusion
and misinformation about how
these things are counted so what exactly
can you just explain again what exactly
the counties will be doing for the next
week and
who is allowed to watch what and
in this process all right so for this
process it's a little bit different than
the auditing process because it's a much
more compact kind of thing it's not as
spread out as we saw in the hand on it
um most counties will have one machine
going um
and i think the rule that we set up not
the went to rule but the interpretation
put out in the official election
bulletin today was a minimum
of two monitors per party per location
plus for any more than two central
scanners you get an additional
one monitor per party so that includes
libertarians they can go up to three
additional monitors at a time per
central scanning unit
and they can again they can watch the
process they can't be intrusive
um they're just there to make sure that
the ballots are being handled properly
they're going through the scanner they
can watch the lma process to make sure
the scanner is counting properly because
that's that's going to publicly
we really want to make sure that that's
done in a transparent way
um and then separate from those people
the investment you said you have three
teams you have the recount team the
recount team
are the county employees and sworn
registrars who can touch ballots and
they're going to be running things for
the
icc then you have the official party and
campaign monitors who will be there
who can watch over the process to make
sure that it's functioning in a fair and
transparent way
and then you have the adjudication teams
which follow the same rules we had
before
will be one republican one democrat and
one election worker for any potential
ties on any ballot where the
initial ballot artifact you cannot
divine the intent of the
voter easily from the from the first
round they'll kick it out it's the same
thing
on this machine most people are doing a
lot of time judication so they'll
be overvotes stray marks that are in the
marginal marks and then i think writings
have to be looked at as well
but those are the different teams of
people who are there and
two groups will have partisans in it to
a have a
role in the process when it comes to
adjudication and then the other group
will be the monitors to make sure the
process has been run fairly and report
back to
their own people the party so i hope
that kind of lays it out for it but
there should be a lot of monitors for
this one
yeah and then um can we get the election
bulletin with the instructions i think
that would be helpful
to have uh in explaining this and then
one more thing i really hate to ask this
but
uh it's floating around out there that
somehow the state election board is
making it where people can't register to
vote unless they own a car
so can you please
if you are registered to vote you're
already registered to vote you don't
want to re-register
you don't have to own a car in order to
vote
uh this is one of those things where
that is one of the one of the things
that a
election worker can look at to see if
you live where you say you live
is you know your car registration
because that's an official government
document
no one is being disenfranchised but we
have asked the counties to
make sure they follow the law both the
spirit and the letter
so that people aren't just moving here
to vote and then going away again
one of the ways to do that is there's
several different pieces of id they can
look at
to verify where you live and that's
that's what that was about
the scp literally changed nothing this
morning all they said to do is for
our office to send an official election
bulletin saying read the law
understand your responsibilities and
know that you know
people have to have some level of proof
that they actually do live where they
say they're
they live but that doesn't seem very
unreasonable in a time like this
thanks gabe thank you all right next is
corsi
hey i'm gabriel in its course but that's
fine
um i was wondering if you could confirm
that this will be
done by machine um because obviously
some people have said they want a hand
recount
and then secondly um you know
kind of re-asking the question of
whether you think this will change the
actual
outcome of who who won you were pretty
clear about that during the hand audit
well i mean it will all be done by
machine
the law defines part of that and the scb
rules specific about we use the central
scanners to rescan
all the ballots in the county or central
scanners you have multiple ones it does
and those final results will be the
final results that are certified
if there's a change now the possibility
of it changing
you know it's 20 20 you never know crazy
things happen but the likelihood is very
low
um we don't expect it to change but
you never know for certain um the hand
recount
that was a we didn't do a recount before
that was a hand audit
in a risk limiting environment so
there's a different set of rules
different different statute we were
operating under this is a very specific
statute
so we're not going to make people do
hand tallies again this is the system
that was intended to be used for an
actual recount post certification
okay we have lecrae mitchell
look right you're still muted
can you hear me now yeah gotcha okay
great how you doing gabe
i'm okay i got coffee now it's been a
long few days
yeah i'm sure um i have two questions
the first
is just i know you just said no changes
were made
from that um skateboard meeting this
morning
i just want to go over again because i
know earlier we said something about
the absentee ballots now being did i get
this right they're mandatory now i have
to start processing them
eight days before instead of like
counties having the option
i just want to make sure saying mccray
was that when it came to the residency
that was there were three agenda items
they moved on the first two they
realized after talking to the attorney
general's office the third in the
residency the law was already there
we just want to put a reminder to the
counties to follow that law
the first thing we did in the sab
meeting this morning was to extend the
drop boxes
because that was an emergency rule and
the second thing was what you just laid
out
we still allow them to begin scanning
15 days out which is basically the three
mondays before the election
but they shall begin to scan that that
for that second monday before the
election which is eight days out uh we
want to make sure that people are taking
full advantage so they can be caught up
by the by the time they get to election
day and only be doing election day
ballots to come in
through tuesday night into wednesday
morning got it
and then my second question i think i
missed the top of the call
i heard someone say something about a
december 2nd midnight deadline
is that did you give timing and if you
could could you just recap the timing on
this
recount i'm sorry they may begin they
may begin scanning tomorrow morning at
9am
on um what is tomorrow morning this
tuesday the
24th at 9 a.m they have to give notice
both on their website publicly post
there but our office knows that we can
post it as well
we want to make sure monitors and the
public has a right to go see these
things
they have to be done with this by
midnight on december 2nd that's midnight
going from december december 2nd
wednesday
into thursday december 3rd so they had a
full wednesday to get done
and we did that with with the full
knowledge obviously thanksgiving
is on thursday and that many of our
counties including three large ones
clayton fulton in dekalb we'll be
running an actual election
on tuesday the the first
okay next is uh quinn scanlon hey gabe
um just a quick clarification
like the audit do counties have to start
with the absentee ballots during the
recount or is that just a suggestion
that's a suggestion and we're gonna give
them some flexibility because
especially in smaller counties you can't
always get the adjudication teams
together
at the exact time you want them so we're
going to give them some flexibility that
they can't get the education team
together
go ahead and start on the things that
don't really need to be adjudicated
which would be the ballot marking device
produce ballots okay great thanks that's
my only question
who's next uh beau evans
hi good um
could you go over in whatever way is
reasonable um what elections are
going to be on december 1st uh
special elections and the ones that jump
off my out of my
brain real quickly are the special
election to phil john the remainder of
john lewis and satan congressional five
uh the special democratic primary to
fill state senate 39 that was
um vacated by congresswoman nakima
williams our congresswoman elected king
of williams now uh the western
district da's race which covers clark
and oconee county
and i know this from various other ones
and counties around the state want to
say seven or eight counties if you email
walter and r we'll get you the rest of
those so those are the three big ones i
know people mainly been talking about
all right of course uh again has one
yeah uh follow up questions um
this is probably a dumb question but
just confirming this is just recounting
the state um presidential votes so the 5
million again
um right yeah there is there's also one
local race in a county i don't know what
it is
that they're within the half a percent
too so we're going to use the same
system to to allow them to account for
that one as well but that's the only
other one i'm aware of is the
presidential race
isn't within a half a percent i never
questioned the recount and one local one
i'll try to track that down
and let walter and all right so they can
get that answer to you awesome
thanks kate brownback
hi gabe um for the notification
requirement
uh as far as when they're gonna be
counting so is it like they have to say
you know we're gonna be counting from
two to four on wednesday
and i don't know do they have to give
specific windows for exactly when
they're
we've asked them to make it more
discreet than
basically given the entire timeline that
they might count in because obviously
very frustrating for monitors
nothing's happening so we're trying to
make them do a little bit better on
being
specific about it going forward
okay and are they supposed to make how
are they supposed to make that public
uh their website they can post it
outside the place and they're supposed
to
send a notification to us so we can put
it on our website as well
okay thanks uh jay morris
jay um mr or miss morris
you're unmuted so you can talk unless
your microphone's not working right oh
you're muted again
try on me one more time
morris okay walter let me
come back to that one let's go to maybe
sarah's next i think
yeah hi eric campbell noonan tops harold
um
i know we're talking about the recount
is it okay if i ask a non-recount
related question
i'm standing here so why not i gotta
tell you what i'm saying
i i see so many people claiming that
they got
all these unsolicited absentee ballots
in the mail now i'm assuming they really
mean they got applications um have you
had any instances of people actually
receiving
unsolicited absentee ballots in the mail
it's just
there's two things that play when it
comes to that particular
situation as you pointed out the vast
majority of these are when they're
getting
dozens and dozens of absentee ballot
applications from you know
different third parties campaigns uh
political parties
and there's a secondary thing that
happened when we came out of the
june primary we had this the absence of
applications went out to all the active
voters
there is a box on there that says if
you're over 65
you can get onto the rollover list which
means that you get a ballot
every single time there is an election
as part of that process as a part of
that regular election season
it doesn't apply to specials but it
applies to everything else so all the
runoffs all the primaries everything
so what happened is a lot of people were
just 65 or over and just checked that
box because yes i'm 65 or over
not realizing they were then asking for
a ballot for the remainder of the year
and a lot of people got things like i
didn't ask for this battle at this time
but they actually did but they just
didn't know that's what they were doing
when they checked the box we
we were able to check specifically on
some of the ones that called us about it
we saw they were on the rollover list
they just didn't know
they were on the rollover so that those
are two different buckets we saw
people saying i got an unsolicited
absentee ballot does that
answer your question pretty well sarah
shoot it with me
you're still muted i can't tell
i hopefully answer your question um do i
try to go back to mr or miss
morris again
it says you're a muted so give it a shot
i don't know you guys have to go with
miss walker right now i'm sorry
mister or miss morris if you want to try
to type something into the chat maybe i
can try to answer that
he just texted me uh we're we're both at
cnn so um
people ask about the details on the
process to adjudicate ballots can you
just talk a little bit about how that's
going to work
um and um you know will ballots be
contested by the parties
on site balance cannot be contested in
this process
there this is not michigan or
pennsylvania where that happens
um what we have here is if the machine
looks at it and says i am not sure
what the um what this ballot
meant to say it goes to an adjudication
module
um that they can look at it
electronically and then you have the
adjudication team which would be one
republican one democrat and one election
worker
all looking at it together and it's sort
of a majority rule
so we can figure out what this person
means it has to be obvious
to the regular person and 99 times out
of 100 when we've seen adjudication
everybody knows what the voter intended
on these things so there's very rarely
anything that's really contentious on
that front
um and let's remember that only about 25
of our overall ballots
are hand marked that are even going to
be a question of what the voter intended
because on the ballot marking device
it is the name that they picked and it's
on the ballot so it's very easy to see
and it's easily scanned so that we
that's what we used to
do the hand audit with to begin with so
the chances of anything really moving
that much
are very low and most of the
adjudication we saw in the general
election
was more based around the handmark paper
ballots in the united states senate race
than the kelly lefler seat with the 21
candidates you had people who were
voting for every republican or every
democrat or every independent
not understanding the rules on that one
so i don't think we're going to see that
many adjudicated ballasts come out of
this process
uh next we have a male moffett hey gabe
a question about this these central
scanners can you kind of describe
um how they operate if how many pages
they can
balance they can do per hour and if you
think they're up to
you know running this continuous loop
and not
having any issues with them well i'm
sure we're going to have to do some
cleaning of them as they go
um but they're designed to do this
they're designed to take this
what you don't want to do is overload
them with too heavy of a stack at a time
we try to do about the the stack size
maybe 50 or 60 to keep running
through and in a really efficient way
you can see him doing about probably 50
ballots a minute
i don't think we'll see it at full
efficiency it'll probably be lower than
that with you know trying to keep up
with everything and
i sent him a call today that slow is
smooth and smooth as fast
you don't want to rush yourself and
cause mistakes and areas you have to go
back and fix so
slow and smooth smooth as fast because
the smoother you do this the better off
you're going to be
a controlled natural stream and flow of
how this should work
should make it all run better so we
imagine that they should
be able to handle this i mean they were
able to handle 1.3 million
scans before they handled 1.1 million
for the
primary occasionally they need to be
clean especially at the hand mark
ballots but i think they're going to be
they're going to do this fine
let's see we have uh miss walker again
sorry
quick follow-up um i'm sorry if i missed
this but in terms of the results on the
scanned recount versus the hand audit do
you expect to see very little
uh discrepancy or virtually no change at
all well
it's 2020 so who knows what to expect on
these things but historically you
very rarely see much movement in the in
the vote total so you can't see coming
out of these things
and you're more likely to see changes
and a hand on it
because there's a lot more human error
in traditional process than you do
through the
using the scanners thank you
well that's all the hands that are up
okay
all right well i appreciate everybody
coming out today
i am praying for our elections workers
that they can be strong to get through
this
and praying that they get to have a good
thanksgiving with their families
and thank you all for helping us get
information out and keeping up the
unprecedented level of transparency at
this office and our county offices
working together
um we will all get through this and
again i appreciate your time we'll be i
know that's some follow-ups just email
ari or walter with the specific
questions on those things we'll try to
get back to you
thanks a lot and have a great day